ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد من علامات
الطائره اثناء عودته من زياره الى الصين
استمر ثلاثه ايام اطلق الرئيس الفرنسي
منويل ماكرون تصريحات الصحفيين اثارت جدلا
وطرحت اسئله عديده بمطالبته اوروبا الا
تصبح تابعه للولايات المتحده
الى الاستيقاظ على حد قوله مشددا على ان
اولويه الاوروبيين عدم التكيف مع اجنده
الاخرين في انحاء العالم وطلب اوروبا
بتقليص ارتباطها بواشنطن وبتجنب مواجهه
محتمله مع الصين بشان تايوان وحسم كرون
دول القاره على مقاومه الضغوط الهادفه الى
تحويلها تابعه لامريكا وفق قوله تصريحات
ماكرون بدت موبلوره لاختلاف واضح مع نهجي
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه والسلفوندرلين
التي زارت بكين الخميس الماضي لكنها لم لم
تلقي وفق تقارير اعلاميه او لم تلقى حفاوه
كحفاوه استقبال ماكرون
كشف بحسب التقارير التمايز في الموقف
الاوروبي هيا للصين حليفه روسيا فالاتحاد
الاوروبي رغم انتقاداته لبكين لكنه لم
يجمع بعد على شكل التعامل لو لم يجمع مع
الصين في خضم التوتر الامريكي الصيني يذكر
مشاهدينا ان حجم اشاره الصين مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي بلغت عام 2020
856 مليار دولار واعتبرت بكينا شركه
التجاريه الرئيسي للاتحاد الاوروبي وفقا
نقلت مطالبه ماكرون لانهاء التبعيه
الاوروبيه لامريكا
من مطالب الرئيس الفرنسي تقليص اعتماد
اوروبا على الدولار الامريكي
ايقاف تبعيه اوروبا للولايات المتحده
تحقيق استقلال استراتيجي للقاره الاوروبيه
وتقليص اعتمادها على السلاح الامريكي
فضلا عن تقليص مصادر الطاقه الامريكيه
وتجنب الانجرار لمواجهه بين بكين وواشنطن
بشان تايوان
نقلت عن ماكرون قوله ان اكبر خطر تواجهه
اوروبا هو التورط في ازمات لا علاقه لها
بها
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا اسامه سيبلاني
ناشر جريده صدى الوطن اهلا بك من باريس
وليد عباس الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بكم ضيوفي
يسمحالي ان ابدا من معك استاذه اسامه كما
تعلم حضرتك ليست بالمره الاولى التي يلقي
فيها مكروه مثل هكذا تصريحات تعتبر قويه
تجاه ادارات بايدن سبقتها كذلك العديد من
التصريحات الاخرى ونستذكر مثلا تلك التي
تتعلق ببيع الغاز وقال بانه لا يعقل بان
اداره بايدن تبعنا اربعه اضعاف ما تبيعه
لداخل الامريكي ولكن هذه المره يتحدث
مكرونه بطريقه اكثر وضوح عن تخفيف التبعيه
تجاه الاداره الامريكيه واتجاه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بشكل عام السؤال الرئيس
هل هناك قدره حقيقيه هل تعتقد بان للرئيس
الفرنسي اليا حقيقيه لتنفيذ ذلك
يعني اولا اعتقد بانه العالم كله يتغير
ويتغير سريعا يعني ما كان حدا يتصور بانه
العالم سيتغير بهذه السرعه
الامبراطوريه العظمى الامريكيه
تخسر
وهجها العالمي بسرعه بسرعه مدهشه والصين
القادمه من الشرق الى العالم
تتوهج وتنتشر
اعتقد بانها ماكرون استطاع ان يعني
يلتقد الفرصه المناسبه
ليحيد اوروبا من الصراع القادم واعتقد
بانه لن لم يتصرف كاحدي
القيادات الاوروبيه واحد من وانما استشار
بعض القيادات الاوروبيه وهنالك
نوع من المزاج الاوروبي الذي يريد
الابتعاد
عن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن ليس
بالقطيعه ولا الانضمام الى الشرق ومحور
الصين بل يريدون من اوروبا ان تكون محورا
عالميا بحد ذاته وهل هناك قدره سيد وليد
على ذلك يعني ضيفه يتحدث كما استمعت له عن
محاوله اوروبيه لتحديد موقفها ولكن حضرتك
تعلم بان المتغيرات التي نعيشها تضطر في
بعض الاوقات الى ان نكون طرفا بشكل او
باخر مكرون يتحدث بصيغه نيته الانفصال ولو
اقتصاديا على الاقل خلينا نقول هل هو قادر
يعني نستعير مقوله صينيه شهيره مسيره
الالف ميل تبدا بخطوه ولكن في كافه
الاحوال هذه المواقف ليست جديده على ذلك
منذ وصوله الى الرئاسه في فرنسا على ضروره
ان يكون هناك سياق استراتيجي اوروبي مستقل
عن كافه القوه الجميع يعرف اننا مقبلون
على عالم متعدد الاقطاب واوروبا لا تريد
ان تكون مجرد تابع لاحد الاخطاب
الامكانيات مما لا شك فيه متوفره ليس
بالضروره على المستوى المباشر الذي نراه
من حيث عظمه وقوه الاقتصاد ولكن اوروبا
تظل سياسيا
لها وجود دولي غايه في الثقه وفي التاثير
تظل زبون كبير بكافه الاطراف كما ذكرت قبل
قليل انها اكبر شريك بالصين او الصين كمان
اكبر شريك لاوروبا على مستوى التجاري اذا
اوروبا اوروبا تتمتع بتطور كبير في مجال
التكنولوجيا اوروبا لديها اوراق كثيره في
لعبتها ولكن المشكله في ان يتفق
الاوروبيون على مواقف محدده او على خطوات
محدده لتحقيق هذا المشروع السابقه
مثال
المانيا موق تقترب من مواقف ماكرون ولكن
بريطانيا مثلا هناك علاقه كبيره وشراكه
كبيره مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هل
تعتقد لم تتحدث عن الاتحاد الاوروبي على
القاره الاوروبيه هل تعتقد بانه قادر ان
يكون هناك توافق على مثل هكذا التوجه
لا يعتبرون بريطانيا جزء من اوروبا او
بالاتحاد الاوروبي وبالتالي عندما يتحدث
عن الاتحاد الاوروبي نتحدث عن القاره
الاوروبيه
عن القاره الاوروبي ولكن القرارات تؤخذ في
الاتحاد الاوروبي اذا بالتالي بالتالي حتى
الالمان الذين كانوا في مرحله ما بالنسبه
لقضيه الدفاع الاوروبي المشترك يعني متشكك
متشككين للغايه وما زالوا متمسكين بالسلاح
الامريكي وبالحلف الاطلسي تغيرت مواقفهم
مؤخرا في كافه الاحوال يرى كثير من
الفرنسيين من المراقبين الفرنسيين انه
ربما من الصعب ان تتحرك اوروبا باعضائها
29 في اتجاه هذا النوع خصوصا مع دول
اوروبا الشرقيه التي تنهج نهج مختلف تماما
ولكنهم يتحدثون عن خلق نواه صلبه من بعض
الدول اوروبا الغربيه تحديدا او الدول
الرائده في مشروع الاوروبي لكي تحدد هذا
المسار وتتفق على مجمل الخطوات التي يمكن
اتخاذها للاستقلال الاستقلال ليس فقط عن
الولايات المتحده ولكن
ايضا عن الصين يعني رفض ايضا ان تكون
اوروبا تحت سطوه الصين
وفي كافه الاحوال المبادره في هذا الامر
كانت للولايات المتحده للولايات المتحده
هي التي بدات تنسحب من العالم منذ ايام
اوباما واكد ترامب على ذلك وبيض يتابع نفس
الطريق فمن الطبيعي ان يبحث الاوروبيون عن
سياق استراتيجي يقفل حمايتهم اولا لا يكفل
ازدهارهم الاقتصاديه والتجاريه ايضا هل
لديك راديو على ما تفضل باهله استاذ وليد
في هذا الاطار لا انا اتفق معه على كل شيء
تفضل به ولكن اضيف بان اوروبا لن تبقى كما
هي اليوم سياسيا طبعا لن يتفق لن نتفق 29
دوله على قرارات مكرونه والمانيا فرنسا
والمانيا ولكن
يعني
الدولتين الكبيرتين في اوروبا فرنسا
والمانيا طبعا
وبريطانيا خارج اللعبه الاوروبيه خرجت من
من
الاوروبي
وهنالك ارتباط تاريخي مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا استطيع ان اقول اليوم بانه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ستترك
بريطانيا او بريطانيا ستترك الولاده
المتحده الامريكي ولكن اجزم بان اوروبا
تتجه الى فصل نفسها عن الاتحاد عن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او الصين
وتجعل من نفسها محور عالمي يقرر بحد ذاته
ماذا سيفعل من اجل مصالحها الخاصه هو في
الواقع استاذ اسامه لماذا تحدثت انا عن
بريطانيا لانه كان هناك
كان هناك مقال ليكن كوبلي في صحيفه
تيليجراف والبريطانيه طبعا هو تحدث وانتقد
كثيرا تصريحات مكرونه حتى انه اعتبر بان
العبثيه من العبث ان يذهب رئيس الفرنسي
لتوطيد علاقتهم على الصين فيما القاره
الاوروبيه تعيش مخاطر قد
تضر
بدمقراطيتها الى اي مدى كلامه يمكن ان
يكون دقيق بحسب قراءتك
اعتقد بانه بانه هذا يعني
نوع من الترهيب لفرنسا وللمانيا عن
الابتعاد عن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وعن الحلف الاطلسي انا اعتقد بانه اوروبا
اليوم تنظر الى اوكرانيا
وتقيس ماذا يجري في اوكرانيا على على
اوروبا امريكا بعيده مثل ما كانت بعيده عن
افغانستان بعيده عن اوكرانيا سوف تقاتل
امريكا حتى اخر اوكرانيا وربما حتى اخر
بولندي او اوروبي وبالتالي اوروبا اليوم
تنظر الى ما يجري في اوكرانيا بانه خطر
على اوروبا اولا وبالتالي
على اوروبا ان تتحرك لفصل نفسها عن
تبعات ما يجري في اوكرانيا وما تريد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من تحقيقه في
اوكرانيا ماذا تريد المتحده الامريكيه في
تحقيقها تريد يعني ان تكسر الروسيه
الاتحاد الروسي وانا اعتقد بان هذه مهمه
مستحيله يعني لن تحصل
وبالتالي الاوروبيون يعرفون بان هذه قضيه
لا يمكن ان تتم ولذلك يجب تحييد اوروبا عن
هذا الصراع هل تعتقد استاذ وليد بانه
اوروبا قادره على ان تحيد بنفسها عن
الصراع الاوكراني الروسي خاصه لما نستذكر
بعض التصريحات الاوروبيه التي تعتبر بان
هذا موضوع وجودي هذا موضوع يخص كل
الاوروبيين والخطر قادم من روسيا وقد يتسع
وقد يمتد الى نقاط اوروبيه اخرى
يعني هو كان امر صعب بالتاكيد لان هذه
الحرب اشتعلت على اراضي في نهايه الامر هي
اراضي اوروبيه ولكن مما لا شك فيه ان
الاوروبيين حاليا ينظرون الى ما وصلنا
اليه في هذه الازمه
وربما يندم البعض على نوع من الانجرار
السريع وراء الموقف الامريكي الامريكيون
دفعوا بقوه
للاشتعال او لتصعيد الازمه مع روسيا في
هذا المجال والدخول في حرب قويه ومباشره
وهذا الامر يشكل عمليه تجاريه مربحه
للسلاح الامريكي وبالتالي من يدفع الثمن
اساسا هم الاوروبيين
ربما تجربه اوكرانيا تحديدا هي التي تدفع
بالرئيس ماكرون اليوم ليقول اننا لا نريد
ان نكون متابعين للولايات المتحده فيما
يتعلق على سبيل المثال بالازمه مع تايوان
نحن هذه ليست الاجنده الاوروبيه
والاجنده الاوروبيه حتى في الازمه
الاوكرانيه كانت محاوله الوصول الى نوع من
التفاهم مع موسكو مع بوتين لحل هذه الازمه
على طاوله المفاوضات وهو ما حاول
الفرنسيون كثيرا ان يقوموا به ولكن الدفع
الامريكي كان قوي للغايه اذا الاوروبيون
اليوم يرون انهم غير مستفيدين من الولايات
المتحده لا على المستوى استراتيجي ولا على
المستوى الاقتصادي وبالعكس يجدون انفسهم
في ازمات بسبب الموقف الامريكيه
كل يوم مع نسب التضخم في مختلف الدول
الاوروبيه
الشكر من باريس وليد عباس هل كتب صحفي
بلاني ناشر جريده الصدى الوطن شكرا لكما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات